one thing is very clear that an infusion
is one of the most controversial
politicians in the world
he is idolized by some and hated by
others but what is for sure is the
Putin's period in office is making its
mark on international politics the truth
is that the government has achieved
little in terms of economic and social
matters under his leadership however his
popularity among Russians remains really
high today in this video we're going to
analyze why Putin is quite so popular in
Russia
[Applause]
so does this Spanish saying that says
after the storm that comes become well
when it comes to Russia this is exactly
what's happened after going through the
tough crisis in the last few years due
to the fall in oil prices as well as the
sanctions received from the
international community for occupying
Crimea the government has been pretty
blunt the difficult times have passed
and the Russian economy is back but
really I mean where's the evidence to
really back this up and tell me what do
you think Russian growth is expected to
be in 2017 12% maybe 9 5 3 2 no well
it's actually predicted to be 1% after a
month the Russian economy keeps growing
for 2017 we're expecting a growth of 1
percent or even more Igor Shuvalov
that sure doesn't look like a lot unless
bearing in mind that Russia is not
exactly a rich country to begin with and
to be honest that 1% is only if we
believe the statistics of the Russian
government's which well more and more
analysts consider to be rather
fictitious the truth is that even though
everything seems to indicate that the
Russian economy is more stable the last
few years have not exactly been easy for
the Russians according to the Russian
social security Institute in the year
2016 alone
Russian citizens suffered from the
biggest loss in purchasing power that
means real income since the 1990s not a
good thing the crisis and the
depreciation of the ruble the Russian
currency has led to this country with a
hundred and forty five million
inhabitants to have a GDP that's similar
to that of Australia which only has a
population of 23 million and what's even
worse is that for now it doesn't look
like the situation is going to improve
so here we come to the great Russian
anomaly evidence which shows that this
country is very different from any other
neither the crisis nor the terrible
economic conditions have damaged the
national popularity of Vladimir Putin in
fact Pitons popularity is today higher
than its pretty much ever being
according to polls from the Levada
Center Putin's approval rating among the
Russian population is almost 80 percent
and now have a look at this
[Music]
but now you might be wondering how is
this even possible why is this man
immune to such a crisis well let's have
a look at just what is happening the
protective father when discussing the
Russian economy it's pretty much
mandatory to talk about oil and raw
materials and here are two pieces of
information so using this an idea of
just how dependent Russia is on these
resources before the fall and the prices
of crude oil oil and natural gas meant a
lot to the Russian economy 70% of the
country's exports and more than 50% of
all income of the Russian government
came from these two commodities and take
a look at the evolution of the price of
oil during the years Putin has been in
office
so anyway well Putin he was incredibly
lucky
right after we reached our the price of
oil which had remained stable around $20
a barrel for the last ten years started
to increase quickly and of course this
meant an amazing flow of money coming
into the country just thinking is an
idea of how significant this was the
share the government contributed to the
economy rose from 35 percent to 70
percent
all of a sudden prosperity came to the
entire nation there were trains
everywhere skyscrapers started to appear
as if they were mushrooms after the rain
and the standard of living for Russians
went up and up and up yeah so it is true
the Putin's authoritarianism could be
felt right from the very beginnings but
I mean so r2 cares the money was flowing
okay so we could see that there was this
sort of agreement between Russian
society and then leader in exchange for
not asking about civil liberties or
corruption the government gave
prosperity and stability to the citizens
in a way tooten became some sort of
protective father to the nation a tough
but capable father who was able to take
care of his children fast as always the
problem is that these situations are
fragile no government not even putin's
has the capacity of achieving this
prosperity all on its own with such high
oil prices Putin didn't conduct any
reforms in Russia I mean what would
really be the point and because of that
when the price of oil started to go
down in the summer of 2014 the economy
of Russia followed the same pattern and
it is here that he comes to the most
interesting part of this story none of
these things effective Putin's
popularity the Russian president knew
for want of a better word how to recycle
his earlier strategy in the beginning he
was the guardian of prosperity now he
would become the leader who would
recover the previous great influence
that Mother Russia used to have
nationalist fervor so if Russia's
economy wasn't having their best moments
well he had to look for another source
of popularity and Putin well he knew
where to find it for 500 years Russia's
foreign policy was all about expanding
its influence since the times of Ivan
the Terrible around the 14th century
Russia expanded its territory on average
eighty square kilometers a day until it
became by far the largest country on
Earth as well as the most powerful
however after the fall of the Soviet
Union the influence of Russia on the
world collapse
so Putin made a new promise and it could
be summarized like this
[Music]
it may not be a prosperous country and
the economic situation may be bad but I
glad Amir Putin will recover Russia's
influence in the world you may not be
your wealthy people but your nation will
be strong but in order to make this
strategy work some things are necessary
the first system is to praise
nationalist sentiments and this means
well Russia Russia and more Russia plan
your Putin unbuild statue of medieval
namesake who United Russian lands by the
way following these same ideals are the
recurring adverts of new invincible
weapons incredibly powerful ones which
will guarantee you Russia gains great
status and global supremacy first of all
though an important question is going to
be whether the Russian government can
actually afford these weapons the second
necessary thing is rather more sinister
and that's going to be for Russia to
find an enemy this enemy is something
that can push Russians towards a common
goal let me explain that a little
service Russia they need a threat they
need an aggressor they need something
for the Russian to unite against and in
order to achieve that Putin requires an
aggressive foreign policy
the Ukrainian crisis the accusations
against NATO and the occupation of
Crimea are all examples that have made
Putin's popularity rise again in the
eyes of the Russians Clinton is taking
Russia back to its previous grandeur
this second strategy you can explain the
busy schedule of Russian diplomacy in
the last few years they may not have
much money but Moscow is everywhere
Ukraine Syria North Africa and hey to be
honest the sanctions the international
community of imposed on Russia has had
kind of the opposite effect that was
intended they have been seen by the
Russian dance humiliating and if they've
had any effect it was to consolidate
popular support for Vladimir Putin 74%
of Russians consider the sanctions to be
an intention to weaken and humiliate
Russia only 5% think of them as an
instrument to stop the conflict in
Ukraine Levada Center and last of all
the Putin it is necessary them to
consolidate the image of a strong
determined leader almost a national hero
something of a savior if you will is no
Russia today if there is no Putin so
these are the keys and understanding why
Vladimir Putin has been able to keep and
even increases popularity he is no
longer the guardian of prosperity but
the leader who will regain the power
that Russia once had crony capitalism
another decisive matter to be considered
is that Putin's government also survives
because he has been able to create a
network of powerful oligarchs around him
who have grown rich thanks to the
resources of the Russian state
government aid and large state contracts
and Putin's commitment to replace
imports have all benefited these
oligarchs Putin's former judo partner
awarded contract to build Russian bridge
to Crimea it'll cost more than three
billion dollars besides Putin has a
back-up plan in case things go awry he
can privatize or more accurately just
give state companies away to these
oligarchs who will use their power and
money to further putin's interest the
russian president has made it clear
though these strategic investors will be
allowed to participate in privatization
and that means only investors who have
been selected by the russian government
iron this are and lest we forget the
repression political repression and the
repression of minorities seems to be
kind of a fetish for dictators and
potential dictators i mean just take a
look at the last report from Amnesty
International on human rights in Russia
it's pretty sad restrictions on rights
freedom of expression Association and
peaceful assembly increased in 2016 well
now we all know the ingredients that
explains Putin's popularity nationalism
oligarchs censorship and political
repression Putin has promised the people
that they will become powerful again in
exchange for their unconditional loyalty
however despite all of this posturing it
does seem kind of unlikely that Russia
is going to be able to seriously compete
with either China or the u.s. in the
medium and the long run but that's our
opinion here a visual politic and as
always we'd love to know what you think
do you think Putin will be successful in
giving Russia its old power back man or
would you prefer national power or maybe
well-being prosperity and freedom we
definitely know what weird ones but we'd
like to know what you would like drop us
a comment below this video and let us
know your thoughts and well if you
enjoyed this video please do give it a
thumbs up below and do not forget to
subscribe abut our brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday and
things don't forget to check out our
friends of the reconsider media
Podcast who provided the voice in this
video that wealth isn't mine
and as always I'll see you in the next
episode
[Music]
you